the click on course offers a clear
explanation London Waterloo was up
across its first store now its parent
company's cutting 5,000 staff lost
commuters are lost customers here
outside too in the shadow of the station
a normally bustling Street is shuttered
Yasmin's convenience store is the only
one open and business is bad
normally the busy is very busy yeah but
at the moment is not busy she too fears
redundancy and budded yeah if I lose my
job I'm not getting another one at this
time doctor may be easing but if you
needed any proof that the way we're
living has changed and this street is
surely it this would normally be heaving
with commuters and tourists alike and
now look at it all the way down here
there are cobblers cafes dry cleaners
all once viable businesses now just
closed there's no football and no sign
of recovery larger names brands built on
our modern lives are feeling it too
redundancies keep coming 500 at Topshop
soner Arcadia 600 at TM Lewin nearly 700
at Harrods and John Lewis says it will
never reopen all its stores emma worked
at Frankie and Benny's in Cardiff for 10
years she was made redundant last week
she's a single mum and says she lies
awake at night with the worry to
suddenly just be pinned off so
expendable it just it makes you feel
like all the hard work was for nothing
and you're just another number you're
just you're just part of the business
that can just be cut off as and when
it's needed so easily you feel like I'm
not human
and then there's aviation airline
easyJet and plane maker Airbus cutting
over 1,500 jobs each and you can exclude
anything because there's so much
uncertainty you know I said in January
if you'd asked me that I'd be standing
here in July telling you about these job
cuts I would have said you're crazy so I
don't know but what we try to do is be
responsible managers much of the pain
has been kept at bay by the furlough
scheme but that starts to taper off next
month its withdrawal needs to be handled
extremely carefully and extremely
sensitively and if it becomes clear that
it's withdrawn simply is
going to leads to mass redundancies from
businesses that would otherwise be
viable the Chancellor is gonna have to
look at slowing down the pace mass
redundancy in this country looms as an
ever more likely threat happier times
fill distant for many Helen Ann Smith
Sky News